courageuse de faire des matinales et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Florence portait Liv bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous mère les
républicains de Taverny c'est dans le
Val-d'Oise vice-présidente de la Région
Île-de-France et soutien pour cette
campagne à la dans la paix à la
présidence pardon des républicains
évidemment en parler vous êtes avec nous
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
et avant de parler de la présidence des
République en quelques questions
d'actualité Florence Portelli Emmanuel
Macron hier a critiqué les scénarios de
la peur concernant les coupures
possibles d'électricité il dit que la
France va tenir nous sommes un grand
pays nous avons un grand modèle
énergétique elle dit le chef de l'État
ça vous a rassuré c'est un en même temps
un peu schizophrène parce que les
scénarios de l'angoisse écoutez c'est
grâce à lui on a tout entendu depuis un
an un sincèrement tout et son contraire
comme d'ailleurs il y a eu tout et son
contraire en matière de politique
énergétique depuis très longtemps dans
ce pays notamment sous François je
rappelle quand même aux gens pourquoi on
en est là c'est parce qu'on a plus de 20
centrales qui sont à l'arrêt et il n'y a
pas de vrai politique énergétique dans
ce pays
c'est aussi de son fait bien sûr ça a
démarré sous François Hollande il y a eu
aussi la pression des vers et puis de
Barbara pompier quand elle était
ministre qui était très anti-nucléaire
aujourd'hui ils sont en train de dire
finalement que le nucléaire est paré de
bonne vertus on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui si on regarde vraiment
des projections en Tera water en fait il
faudrait au moins 400 terawattheure de
plus pour qu'on arrive à une vraie
indépendance entre guillemets
énergétique pour ça il faudrait
construire à peu près 20 EPS
supplémentaires il faudrait remettre en
plus en circulation des 56 centrales
donc c'est des sujets qui sont
extrêmement compliqués on ne sait pas où
on va sincèrement et après concernant le
court terme c'est vrai qu'on a entendu
des scénarios absolument apocalyptiques
et en même temps sans vrais réflexion
sur ce qui va être fait moi j'ai été
sidéré à désinvolture par exemple
exemple de papendaye qui dit ah bah
c'est pas grave s'il n'y a pas
d'électricité on n'a qu'à fermer les
écoles vraiment des comptes oui parce
que on a sacrifié nos enfants pendant le
covid j'ai pas que la sécurité situation
était facile et qu'on aurait fait mieux
mais le devoir d'un peu politique c'est
de transmettre à ses enfants et
transmettre une société meilleure
considérer que l'école est une variable
d'ajustement je trouve que c'est d'une
inconscient sidérante donc nous des
maires de France parce que je suis aussi
présidente de l'Association des maires
de France nous demandons d'ailleurs à ce
que les coutures ne soient pas annoncées
à 17h quand nos agents territoriaux
repartent chez eux mais à midi vous avez
été entendu là-dessus
parce que nous si vous voulez la maman
de l'idéologie on est aussi les les
tenants du bon sens nous les mers qu'on
entend de cette demande et puis
consacralise des secteurs justement
comme les écoles et des crèches
un mot sur les carburants puisque la
ristourne à la pompe prendra fin au 31
décembre prochain et ce matin sur RTL
Elisabeth borne annonce au dispositif de
remplacement ça serait une prime de 100
euros pour 10 millions de français à
partir de 1er janvier 2023 10 millions
de Français c'est la moitié des ménages
pour vous c'est le bon ciblage si tu la
bonne réponse oui écouter moi je suis
pas dans la critique systématique je
veux pas critique dans pour des foyers
qui sont en grande situation de
précarité ou de difficulté mais il
fallait cibler il fallait arrêter la
ristour pour tout le monde pour vous
mais je pense surtout que plus rien
étonnable vous savez un jour quand on se
posera vraiment les bonnes questions sur
la dette du pays la dette du pays le
fait que nous créanciers soient les
Allemands explique aussi beaucoup de
choix en matière de politique
énergétique donc le problème de la dette
qui va payer un moment qu'est-ce qu'on
transmet aussi à nos enfants là-dessus
il y a pas de la planète qui est
endettée sur le plan écologique il y a
aussi notre portefeuille on va parler du
débat sur l'immigration oui qui a eu
lieu hier à l'Assemblée donc Elisabeth
borne a présenté les grandes lignes du
futur projet de loi
que vous avez attendu est-ce que vous
voteriez ce projet de loi je suis pas
parlementaire moi en tous les cas dans
mon ma famille politique il y a un vrai
débat sur le problème des travailleurs
qui viennent en France pour des secteurs
dit en tension et on considère que c'est
un très mauvais appel ça veut pas dire
qu'on est contre l'immigration choisie
en tous les cas qu'on est contre les
immigrés en de manière globale parce que
souvent on entend des propos assez
caricaturaux sur la droite mais cet
appel d'air n'est pas souhaitable je
vais vous dire pourquoi moi je suis
maire de banlieue et
on a déjà énormément de difficultés à
intégrer tout le monde quand je dis
intégrer tout le monde c'est pas logique
quelqu'un n'importe comment et puis
après détourner le regard et ne pas
regarder ce qui se passe la vraie
intégration avec associé un vrai
sentiment de dignité pour les gens ce
n'est pas ça et si on veut vraiment
intégrer tout le monde on ne peut pas
faire des appels d'air à ce point-là
a dit que c'était pas un appel d'air qui
avait pas de plan régularisation massif
qu'il fallait avoir travaillé en France
depuis plusieurs mois il résidait depuis
plusieurs années ça vous a pas non parce
que déjà ils ont même pas été ils n'ont
même pas été capable de gérer la
situation après des des grands cris de
cowboy de Gérald Darmanin sur la
situation des migrants et de problèmes
que nous avons eu quand même maritime
de manière globale moi ce qui me choque
aussi mais c'est un problème politique
global depuis le quinquennat d'ailleurs
je trouve qu'on raisonne à court terme
on a des secteurs en tension d'ailleurs
pratiquement partout sincèrement à
chaque fois on cite la restauration mais
il y a pas de la restauration vous
parlez à n'importe quel entrepreneur il
vous dit qu'il a énormément de mal à
recruter juste le vrai problème le vrai
problème et moi j'aimerais bien que chez
nous dans ma famille politique on se
penche là dessus c'est sincèrement un
problème d'école et d'éducation pourquoi
aujourd'hui les jeunes n'ont pas
forcément envie de travailler pas tous
hein mais il y en a ils ont envie de
moins en moins de travailler et le covid
a accentué ça donc on peut sincèrement
se poser les bonnes questions pourquoi
on manque de CF pourquoi on n'a pas une
vraie politique de l'éducation par la
voix de l'alternance pourquoi
c'est un problème de cursus scolaire
est-ce que le collège unique était un
bilan satisfaisant je ne crois pas
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas plus remplacer
les lycées professionnels par des CFA je
le pense sincère mais là si vous êtes
sur le moyen terme mais sur le court
terme certains de vos collègues députés
disent donc nous dans nos
circonscriptions on a des taux de
chômage qui sont extrêmement bas et les
patrons demandent à ce qu'on puisse
recruter écouter moi sur le terrain j'ai
une zone d'activité avec énormément
d'entreprises les patrons me disent tous
on a de l'emploi on a des jeunes chez
vous qui ont besoin justement de
travailler pourquoi ils ne viennent pas
se former chez nous donc le court terme
ce serait par exemple quelle école que
dans les lycées les chefs d'entreprise
viennent faire la promotion de leur
entreprise ça voudrait dire aussi que
l'école l'éducation nationale et le
monde de l'entreprise n'est pas
cloisonné en réalité encore une fois on
ne raisonne pas je sais pas si vous
lisiez roule tabi quand vous étiez plus
jeune mais on ne raisonne pas par le bon
bout de la raison le problème dans ce
pays c'est les codes le problème c'est
la formation et on en parle plus du tout
dans la classe politique aujourd'hui on
parle d'immigration mais par le petit
bout de la garniette et de pouvoir
d'achat c'est très important je ne dis
pas que ce n'est pas important mais qui
parle de la transmission qui part de
l'éducation qui parle de l'orientation
on va parler de la dans le sujet on va
parler de la présidente de votre partie
vous avez annoncé votre soutien Éric
ciotier alors pourquoi ce chat et
pourquoi avoir attendu le
l'entre-deux-tours mais justement notre
deux tours c'est le moment du
rassemblement et j'avais été contacté
plusieurs fois par érikiotique il y
avait vraiment une démarche d'ouverture
que j'ai particulièrement appréciée et
d'ouverture en connaissant mes
différences et en connaissant mon esprit
très libre et quand il m'a recontacté au
lendemain du premier tour je lui ai dit
que j'étais prête en effet rentrer dans
une logique de rassemblement parce que
plutôt que de critiquer d'observer ce
qui se passe dans mon parti je préfère
être dedans essayer de changer les
choses de l'intérieur
il m'a donné des gages pour que ma voix
soit entendue notamment sur les
questions d'éducation transmission
d'indépendance du pays et de
réindustrialisation qui sont mes grands
sujets avec l'identité territoriale de
quelle manière vous allez la faire
entendre ça doit vous aurez une place
particulière si il était le dimanche a
priori oui mais même si je ne l'ai pas
en tous les cas je compte la faire
entendre je lui fais plutôt confiance en
tous les cas il a montré des gages
d'ouverture c'est quelqu'un avec qui
j'ai toujours une bonne relation qui est
plutôt sympa et ouvert dans tous les cas
qui me l'a qui me l'a garantit mais je
pense qu'au-delà de ça c'est la survie
de la droite républicaine qui est en jeu
et aujourd'hui une place de
vice-président j'en sais rien vous savez
je suis pas dans les comptes
d'apothicaire ça ne m'intéresse pas moi
je suis dans les idées on va venir sur
sur la ligne mais en quoi il se tient
carne plus le rassemblement que vous ne
Retailleau pour vous c'est pas contre
Bruno Retailleau que j'estime énormément
c'est quelqu'un qui est très intelligent
pour qui j'ai beaucoup de et j'ai des
amis d'ailleurs qui étaient dans les
différents camps vous savez on est dans
le même parti politique c'est pas une
guerre en dehors des LR
c'est pas contre un adversaire politique
c'est une compétition donc à partir de
là il faut faire des choix il y a une
dynamique pour erikioti c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a montré qu'il était prêt à
rassemblé en écoutant les différences et
les singularités je suis en donuts
j'aime bien lui faire confiance parce
que je le connais depuis un certain
temps et puis on verra alors justement
vous disiez il m'a donné des gages pour
faire vivre les idées de Philippe Seguin
est-ce que le gaullisme social
aujourd'hui c'est pas plus c'était pas
plus Aurélien Pradier que
Eric Ciotti alors il vous appelle
échappé qu'Aurélien Pradier n'est pas
présent au second tour après je voulais
pas soutenu au premier non mais le
problème du de des étiquettes et
d'enfermer les gens dans des cases moi
je pense que le meilleur c'est gagné
c'était Philippe Seguin comme le
meilleur filmiste c'était François
Fillon donc moi personnellement j'ai un
héritage qui est celui-ci Seguin je
considère d'ailleurs que les questions
d'identité avaient été portées très
fortement par nuit au moment du traité
sur Maastricht qui n'est avec des
questions qui n'ont jamais été résolues
par la droite
est en tête du premier tour et qui
devrait gagner dimanche m'a donné des
gages aussi pour que nous ayons une
réflexion par rapport à cela alors ça
c'est sur les questions d'identité mais
sur le plan économique parce qu'avec
sottis son programme c'est une baisse
massive des impôts ce qui est plutôt
libéral est-ce que c'est compatible avec
ce qui était Philippe Séguin est-ce que
la ligne d'éxi est compatible avec le
Seigneur
pendant toute la matinée
moi j'ai décidé d'arrêter d'être la
porte-parole de Pierre Paul Jacques
parce que je suis de ma porte-parole
toute seule et comme en plus on manque
de femmes qui s'exprime qui vous paraît
compatibles sur Philippe Seguin c'était
à la fois quelqu'un de profondément
critique sur la construction européenne
telle qu'elle s'est faite et qui
contrairement à ce qu'on dit n'était pas
anti-européen et en même temps c'était
un libéral Philippe Seguin président de
la Cour des comptes était profondément
libéral c'est absolument pas compatible
le problème dans ce pays c'est aussi
comment vous définissez de libéralisme
c'est pas du de l'ultra libéralisme qui
saccage des services publics ce n'est
pas ça donc des bureaucratisés des taxer
un pays qui les énormément peut très
bien trouver du sens dans la France que
souhaitait Philippe Seguin sur la ligne
justement parce que c'est important vous
dites que vous pensez avoir de la place
pour imposer vos idées ça veut dire que
pour vous il n'y aura pas de
droitisation du parti de la ligne
modérée aura toujours sa place avec Éric
sottis il emporte en hydrotisée ni
modéré c'est et je pense d'ailleurs que
on meurt dans notre démocratie de
l'enfermement dans des cases parce qu'on
et d'ailleurs c'est le meilleur moyen
pour ne pas approfondir les idées c'est
tiens à tel il est très à droite tiens à
tel il est modéré ce qui d'ailleurs
souvent sous-entend pour certains un peu
neuneu et sans conviction profonde moi
je crois que tout simplement il est
temps de définir qui nous sommes pas
nous définir par rapport à l'aile gauche
à l'aide droite ou à elle du plafond ou
du sous-sol mais de dire enfin qu'est-ce
qu'est la droite aujourd'hui dans le
monde de demain dans le monde
international aussi dans lequel nous
vivons et dans l'Europe aussi telle
qu'elle s'est construite et telle
qu'elle sait aussi déconstruite et
comment c'est un vaste chantier que nous
n'avons toujours pas mené jusqu'au bout
et comment exister entre Emmanuel Macron
et Marine Le Pen c'est aussi ça la
question vous pensez qu'il y a encore
mais moi ça ça ne m'intéresse pas je me
fiche complètement de ce que pensent
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen faisait
partie en grande partie chez Emmanuel
Macron chez Marine Le Pen vous savez
quand vous n'êtes pas capable de dire
qui vous êtes et d'ailleurs c'est assez
intéressant souvent on a même du mal à
trouver nos propres slogans on est
et peu d'incarner mais d'ailleurs le
propre du rassemblement c'est qu'il ne
m'incarnera pas tout seul alors déjà je
lui fais encore une fois entièrement
confiance là-dessus mais n'entourer de
gens qui ont des parcours différents qui
ont des traditions différentes mais qui
ont tous un point commun c'est des
valeurs justement de droite en matière
d'autorité en matière d'identité et en
matière aussi de respect des services
publics qui sont fortement malmenés dans
ce pays alors Erics a été soutenue on le
sait par Laurent Wauquiez pendant cette
campagne est-ce que Laurent Wauquiez
sera le futur candidat des républicains
à l'élection présidentielle prochaine
alors ça j'en sais rien du tout vous le
souhaitez d'ailleurs j'ai pas dit que je
ne souhaitais j'ai dit Erik j'étais
d'accord avec lui sur un constat c'est
qu'on s'est très très mal débrouillé
pour désigner notre candidat à quelques
mois d'élection présidentielle ça a
énormément pénalisé Valérie Pécresse
parce que le parti n'était pas en ordre
de marche comme il le fallait n'était
pas prêt donc on était beaucoup trop
près il faut en tous les cas qu'on ait
notre mode de désignation qui soit
entériné beaucoup plus tôt et là-dessus
je le rejoins entièrement
on verra qui sera candidat ou candidate
donc là dessus vous le rejoignez pas de
dire ça sera Laurent Wauquiez on va le
dire dès le début 2023 ça sera lui et
personne d'autre ça vous le rejoignez
pas là-dessus c'est ce qu'il a mis dans
son programme c'est qu'il fallait
définir la ligne et le candidat beaucoup
plus tôt que ce que l'on avait fait
entièrement d'accord avec ça sera le
rembourser écouter Éric Ciotti ne m'a
pas demandé d'être son clone donc non
mais là dessus vous n'êtes pas d'accord
sur le fait qu'il faut dire que c'est le
invoquer tout de suite ah non mais là je
vous dirai jamais que c'est Laurent
Wauquiez tout de suite déjà pour la
première des raisons c'est quelle est
notre programme quelles sont nos idées
qu'est-ce qu'on va défendre je ne
connais pas celle de Laurent Wauquiez
pour demain comme je ne connais pas
celle des éventuels entre plusieurs
candidats en tous les cas
qu'il y ait des une ligne qui se dégage
qu'il y a un fond qui se dégage et après
on verra qui sera le mieux à même de le
porter je pense qu'il n'y a rien qui se
ferme Éric Ciotti a droit d'avoir ses
préférences moi j'aurais aussi d'avoir
des miennes et d'avoir mon parcours ce
qui est sûr c'est
laquelle votre préférence la préférence
c'est pour la personne qui défendra
l'indépendance du pays qui défendra la
transmission d'éducation il y a pas de
nom encore en revanche ça pourrait
d'accord avec je suis d'accord avec le
programme d'érectionnotique est un
programme justement de présidents d'un
parti politique sur la méthode de
désignation d'un candidat et je pense
qu'il a raison on est parti beaucoup
trop tard et ça a pénalisé notre
candidate que je suis fière d'avoir
soutenu on va en parler justement on va
les répéter sa campagne on a envie de
vous demander comment est-ce qu'elle va
aujourd'hui est-ce que la défaite est
digérée derrière elle écoutait elle va
très très bien surtout qu'elle a
beaucoup de sujets en tant que
présidente de région vu ce que nous fait
de gouvernement est-ce qu'il fait de
manière globale de collectivités
territoriales c'est c'est pas une petite
fille c'est une femme courageuse qui
voilà a subi une défaite qui était quand
même particulièrement lourde pour
certains assez injustes au niveau de
l'ampleur du du score qui était vraiment
très bas est-ce qu'elle est prête à
revenir sur la scène nationale
aujourd'hui écouter c'est elle qu'il
faut poser la question moi je pense
qu'elle ne l'a pas quitté la scène
nationale c'est juste qu'aujourd'hui on
a des priorités on parle beaucoup de sa
région
c'est la première région de France à la
région de France sur plein d'aspects et
on va en parler puisque parmi les gros
dossiers à gérer il y a évidemment le
dossier des transports une augmentation
du passe Navigo a été annoncé hier il
passera plus de 84 euros en 2023 est-ce
que c'est aux usagers franciliens de
payer surtout dans le contexte
d'inflation actuel c'est la question que
nous avons posée au gouvernement je vous
signale que il y a encore peu de temps
nous allions jusqu'à 100 euros par mois
ce qui n'était pas possible patenables
et je regrette énormément que le
gouvernement ait fini par fléchir après
avoir mené une politique une tambouille
politicienne absolument indigne sur le
dos des usagers par exemple quand le
ministre des Transports vous dit si on
doit augmenter si la région n'arrive pas
à assumer c'est parce que les
collectivités territoriales germales ce
qui est un discours que nous entendons
très souvent de la part de l'État
surtout
ça me rappelle un sketch des Inconnus où
il dit il ne faut pas prendre les gens
pour des mais il faut pas oublier qu'ils
le sont pardon pour le terme mais c'est
Jacques Beauregard qui est un peu qui
est relooké par des publicitaires
cyniques moi je pense qu'on prend
vraiment des gens pour des imbéciles
n'importe qui qui m'écoutent alors que
je ne fais pas de la politique
politicienne si je lui dis en région
Île-de-France il y a à peu près 10
millions de voyageurs par jour 9
millions 5 en Occitanie 66000 par jour
comment vous pouvez comparer un besoin
non mais besoin d'une région qui a 66
000 voyageurs par jour et l'autre
pratiquement 10 millions
c'est une blague donc le problème de la
région Île-de-France c'est que nous
avons énormément de lignes de bus de
métro de tramway de RER nous faisons en
plus des trains et des RER et des bus et
des métros nouvelle génération nous
remplissons le matériel roulant qui
était extrêmement vétus nous prolongeons
des lignes de métro nous créons des
nouvelles lignes comment voulez-vous que
ça n'est pas un impact avec l'explosion
du coût de l'énergie donc tout le monde
l'a compris Valérie Pécresse a même été
défendu par ses adversaires politiques
par Jean-Paul Duchon qui avait battu à
la tête de la région qui a dit que
franchement c'était un procès en ligne
qui lui était fait et nous avons rappelé
l'engagement d'Édouard Philippe
d'orphine ancien Premier ministre
Emmanuel Macron qui disait que
Île-de-France mobilité qui gère les
transports en Île-de-France ne pouvaient
pas
continuer comme cela avec tout ce qu'on
lui demandait sans recette
supplémentaire donc la LED de 200 000
annoncé par le gouvernement vous en êtes
satisfaite j'en suis satisfaite à court
terme je sais qu'ils sont dans le court
terme ces gens-là mais il va falloir
quand même réfléchir à la suite et comme
je vous le disais nous avons des
nouvelles lignes qui arrivent du à la
demande de l'État également et il va
falloir à interrogé sur le les modalités
de 84 euros c'est acceptable pour les
gens comment le Pass à 84 euros c'est
acceptable
que à 100 euros par mois mais vous
pensez que ça va être accepté avec des
gens qui ont qui sont dans des trains
bondés il y a moins en moins de gens
justement de plus en plus de difficultés
là c'est à coup de milliard qu'on
investit dans les transports pour qu'on
ait plus les trains bandés pour qu'on
ait des lignes qu'on est plus de
matériel roulant sur le meilleur qualité
qu'il y ait des lignes qui soient
étendues qu'on électrifie même des
lignes qui marchaient de manière
complètement dingue la ligne Provin
Paris n'était toujours pas une
électrifiée avant qu'on arrive enfin
c'était complètement aberrant donc on
parle un peu en part de la préhistoire
en matière de ça les gens ils vont le
voir quand quand
je viens vous voir sauf quand les
personnels sont en grève comme c'est le
cas encore aujourd'hui ce qui est assez
pénible le matériel a quand même
profondément
je ne suis contre le droit de grève qui
a un droit constitutionnel en revanche
je rappelle aussi que la continuité du
service public est un droit également
constitutionnel que la conciliation
entre les deux s'appelle un service
minimum mais qui a franchement un abus
de grève on en a ras-le-bol moi ça fait
plus de 20 ans que je prends les
transports en commun j'ai connu tous les
grands mouvements de grève et à un
moment de la prise en otage des usagers
ou quand ça intervient parfois à la
veille d'un pont je vous assure que vous
avez beau être pour nos droits de grève
il y a un moment vous avez vraiment
l'impression quand même peut-être pris
encore une fois pour un imbécile
vous avez demandé au groupe LR à
l'Assemblée nationale de faire une
proposition de loi afin de faciliter
l'expulsion et vous préciser sans aucune
possibilité de relogement dans le parc
social les familles de délinquants
d'abord est-ce que vous avez été entendu
par le groupe ecoutez c'est tout frais
en tout cas j'étais entendu par Éric
sciotique il m'avait répondu qu'il
trouvait la proposition intéressante
encore une fois c'est pas la méchante
droite contre les pauvres gens qui
seraient dans des logements sociaux au
contraire je vous disais que je suis
fière d'être mère de banlieue à Taverny
et nous avons des logements sociaux où
les gens qui sont dedans ne demandent
qu'à vivre dans la dignité la sécurité
pour moi faire du social c'est assurer
aussi dans les quartiers prioritaires on
puisse vivre avec dignité aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas quand vous avez un
logement social c'est à vie c'est
extrêmement compliqué d'expulser et la
vraie question qu'on peut se poser là
encore je reviens à la quête de sens
c'est quel est le sens des choses quand
vous avez un logement public finalement
à vie et qui n'induit pas des devoirs
pour expulser c'est extrêmement
compliqué ça prend énormément de temps
c'est un partenariat avec le bailleur ça
peut pourrir de la vie d'un quartier ça
peut mettre en danger des enfants et des
familles quand il y a du trafic de
drogue ce n'est pas normal possibilité
de relogement dans le parc social ça
veut dire que ces familles vont ou ça
change dans le privé c'est beaucoup plus
dur de trouver un logement
ça ne va pas de soi d'avoir un logement
à vie dans le parc public ça veut dire
qu'on les envoie éventuellement dans la
rue est-ce que finalement en France
de deux le l'avantage au moins de ne pas
considérer que vous avez un logement
social vis-à-vis c'est que ça vous
oblige aussi à avoir un comportement
pardon de dire ça ma comportement adulte
quand vous commencez dans la vie active
et qu'au début vous avez un pouvoir
d'achat limité vous échelonner les
perspectives d'avenir en vous disant ben
voilà tellement moi je gagnerai plus je
ou pas je vais pouvoir m'agrandir ou pas
et vous prévoyez un schéma de vie
comment vous pouvez vous élever et
prévoir un schéma de vie pour vous votre
famille et vos enfants quand finalement
vous savez que quoi qu'il arrive vous
restez vous êtes cantonné à cela et
d'ailleurs souvent les gens qui sont
dans des réseaux sociaux à vie
n'acceptent jamais la propriété ne
transmettent rien à leurs enfants moi
j'appelle vraiment une réflexion sur le
sens du logement public dans ce qu'on
vous demande merci
bien sûr oui que ce soit réviser
régulièrement comme dans le privé et
merci François merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin regardez une
de la dépêche vaccination covid de la
France en retard cette année de votre
journal Christelle merci Christelle
merci Florence Portet Lyon face au club
des territoires